organizations today are looking for ways
to streamline the migration of existing
applications to kubernetes in this video
we're going to look at a couple
offerings from google cloud that can
drastically reduce the complexity around
getting existing workloads running in
kubernetes migrate for gke and gke
autopilot
let's start with a brief overview of gke
autopilot kubernetes is extremely
powerful but can be a challenge to set
up and manage by yourself provisioning
and managing resources security and
network configuration and scaling can
all be challenging to help alleviate
some of these issues google cloud has
long offered google kubernetes engine as
a managed service by using gke in
standard mode customers still provision
and manage the underlying infrastructure
but the vast majority of the
configuration is handled by google this
is a great solution for customers who
still want to maintain a degree of
control for example if they want to use
gpu instances however for customers who
want to run mainstream workloads and
don't want to worry about configuring
infrastructure google cloud recently
introduced gke autopilot with autopilot
mode clusters customers don't have to
worry about the underlying
infrastructure at all
google cloud essentially becomes your
site reliability engineer scaling the
cluster up and down as needed you simply
choose which workloads need to run there
and google cloud does a bunch of the
heavy lifting for you
gke autopilot provides several key
benefits to customers first optimize
production like a kubernetes expert
google creates clusters according to
battle tested and hardened best
practices that yield optimized
configuration and security posture ready
for production helping you reduce gke
learning curve and get to production
faster
strong security posture
google takes full responsibility for
nodes and infrastructure security
eliminating infrastructure security
management tasks
reduce day two operations google
monitors the entire autopilot cluster
control plane worker nodes and core
kubernetes system components ensuring
your pods are always scheduled
improve resource efficiency google takes
full responsibility for optimizing your
resource consumption you pay only for
the pods not for the nodes so you have
an easy way to run kubernetes with gke
autopilot how can you easily get
existing workloads onto those clusters
for those of you not familiar with
migrate for gke this solution can be a
really useful tool in your app
modernization toolset to accelerate and
simplify your enterprise's application
modernization journey to gke you have
the option to use migrate for gke as is
to accelerate your end customer
modernization or build your proprietary
automations on top of the product to
increase productivity of your
modernization projects either way it can
drastically reduce the time it takes to
move workloads from vms into containers
when looking at migrating an existing
workload there are four discrete steps
that you'll want to go through first is
discovery and assessment migrate has a
fit assessment tool that can be used to
help identify what workloads you have
running and which are the best candidate
for migration look into the fit
assessment tool video for more
information
next is setup and planning migrated
workloads can run on gke in standard or
autopilot mode as well as on anthos and
even cloud run
additionally you can orchestrate
migration pipelines to help automate the
migration process
in this video we're focused on the third
phase so i won't spend a lot of time
here
the final phase deals with how you
manage applications after they have been
migrated because migrate for gke
provides you with the resulting docker
file you can easily manage updates to
your code via standard deployment
pipelines
drilling down a bit into the steps
associated with that third phase and
what you'll see in the upcoming demo is
the general migrate for gke workflow
when it comes to an actual migration
first we're going to create a gke
autopilot cluster then we're going to
provide migrate for gke a source vm the
migration processes will inspect the vm
and then generate a migration plan that
we can edit as needed from there it will
generate the deployment artifacts
including a docker container we'll then
deploy that container onto our autopilot
cluster
with that let's jump into our demo we'll
start the demo by building out our
autopilot cluster notice that all i need
to do is provide a name for the cluster
and the region in which it's going to
run
and now that our cluster is up and
running we can move on to deploying our
sample application
okay so let's deploy the kubernetes
jammel and notice that's creating a
bunch of services and while they're
created autopilot is increasing the
resource requirements automatically for
us to address those new services now
that that's around let's check our pods
they're still impending let's check them
again here a little bit later and
everything is up and running so we can
test the service now i'm going to get
the front end service ip address i'm
going to navigate into my web browser
and you can see here the application is
running let me go in i'm going to buy an
item and then i'm going to go ahead and
check out and you see everything working
exactly as you would expect it to the
way the application works is every
service except for the payment service
is running in kubernetes the payment
service is in a vm and that's what we're
going to migrate but first we need to
stop that vm so we can migrate it so
let's do that now
to perform the actual migration i
switched over to migrate for containers
i'm going to click create migration i'll
give my migration a name i'll select a
source that i created earlier it's a
linux vm we'll give it that vm name and
we're going to migrate the image with
that i'll click create migration and
this will go off it'll take a little bit
of time so i'll speed up the video and
i'll rejoin you when it's finished
our migration is completed so what i'm
going to do now is i'm going to come in
and i'm going to review and edit the
migration plan that was generated what
we're going to do first is we're going
to come in and make a change to this v2k
service manager variable and set that to
true
that lets allows us to use the enhanced
runtime to run on gke autopilot and
we're going to change the name of the
image from payment service vm to payment
service and the same thing for the
kubernetes service since it's no longer
running at a vm we'll generate our
artifacts
that takes a while so let me speed up
the video here and i'll rejoin you when
it's complete
so this process is almost wrapped up
what we're going to do here is we're
going to take a look after it finishes
at the artifacts that were generated you
can see we have a couple of docker
images as well as the docker file and
some other artifacts i'm going to go
ahead and download those into cloud
shell so i'll get artifacts from my
migration if i look in the directory you
can see those
artifacts that i mentioned previously
let's go ahead and apply
the deployment spec that was generated
this is going to deploy our new payment
service so we'll do a kube ctl apply
minus f deployment spec that's creating
the new service and a new deployment
in kubernetes clear the screen and let's
check and see the status of those pods
this might take a few seconds
all right let's just wait for those to
come up and we'll speed up the video
all right now that that has is up and
running that new service what we're
going to do is we're going to check our
app to see if it actually is all working
again so we'll buy this camera add the
clock cart
place order
and everything is working exactly as
expected we have migrated the payment
service from the vm into the container
i hope that demo showed you how easy it
can be to not only deploy a gke
autopilot cluster but also how simple it
can be to migrate an existing vm based
workload to kubernetes for more detailed
information check out our documentation
as well as the other videos in our
migrate series and don't forget to like
and subscribe to be alerted whenever we
publish new content
[Music]